Hello, and welcome to another Unreal Engine training session.
This time we're going to take a look at lighting, specifically an introduction for architecture,
engineering, and construction industries.
My name is James Burton, and I'm an Unreal Engine instructor.
And in this course, we're going to be taking a look at the following topics.
First of all, we'll be covering lighting terminology and types, so the types of lights that you
have available in Unreal Engine, as well as going over some basic concepts to make sure
that we have some common ground and understand what we're talking about when referring to lighting.
We'll be taking a look at how we can control exposure and what tools we have to our disposal.
Then we'll be taking a look at Lumen, which is Unreal Engine's default lighting system,
which is a dynamic global illumination system that's really, really cool.
And then we'll be taking a look at creating some specific examples.
So since we're looking at architecture, engineering, construction, we're going to look at how to make
natural exterior lighting.
We'll also take a look at Lumen's reflection system and how we can get the most out of it,
as well as creating some examples of interior lighting to make sure that we cover the whole spectrum.
So I hope you have fun with me, but let's go ahead and get started.